[Music]
on this wednesday night
death devastation and despair in beirut
the buildings decimated
the search for survivors after a blast
that changed lives
in a flash
and accusations negligence is what led
to the disaster
ottawa's new deal to buy millions of
doses of coronavirus vaccine
when could they be ready and who will
likely get it first
america's november election could push
the envelope the fears democracy
can't depend on the u.s postal service
and
bubble plea it sounds like a reasonable
plan
two tiny towns that need each other but
are cut off by an international border
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
in beirut tonight there's a mixture of
grief and exhaustion plus
demands for answers as new details
emerged that negligence may have led to
the massive explosion in the port
beirut city governor says half the city
has been damaged
this was one moment of relief crews
pulled this young man from the rubble
he'd been trapped for more than 10 hours
others though are still trapped and
rescuers are working through the night
using flashlights to search for signs of
life
but with so many buildings to search
they're struggling to keep up
a two-week state of emergency has now
been declared up to three hundred
thousand people have
no home to go back to and the popular
waterfront neighborhood bars and
restaurants have been reduced
to rubble more than 135 people are known
to have died and that number is likely
to rise
over 5 000 people are injured and
treating them
has become a major challenge according
to the world health organization
three of beirut's hospitals were so
badly damaged
they can't even accept patients the
cause of the explosion is still
under investigation and the crater it
left behind in the port is
massive everything near it is
obliterated lebanon's prime minister
says more than 2 700 tons of ammonium
nitrate
confiscated from a ship had been stored
there for more than six years without
proper safety measures
reuters reports a team of inspectors
warned six months ago if it wasn't
removed
it could blow up all of beirut
a number of port officials have been put
under house arrest
in a city scarred by years of civil war
and bombings nothing has been as
devastating as this
crystal commencing on how life in beirut
changed
in an instant
the debris field still being searched
stretches for
kilometers and the work is grim down
every street
boulders of concrete mangled metal and
broken glass
the shop owner says i lived through the
war and tough circumstances
but i never saw something like this
before
israel ziblani was in downtown beirut
happily posing for a video in her
wedding dress
when the blast happened
2700 tons of ammonium nitrate
exploded but it's not clear what caused
the blast
according to lebanon's prime minister
hassan diab
it's been stored at the port for years
the shipment was traveling from georgia
to mozambique in 2013 but the vessel
made an
unexpected stop at the port because of
mechanical issues
the delay was long and the crew
eventually abandoned the ship
there are reports that port officials
wrote several letters requesting
government authorities
deal with the potentially dangerous
material
the president is vowing to hold those
responsible to account
pending an investigation all port
officials have been put under house
arrest
a move that comes amid allegations of
negligence
speechless really i can't i can't say
much except that
you know we feel so sorry for the losses
that we had
taking in the destruction beirut's mayor
says the city
can come back in time but rebuilding
would cost
millions and lebanon is virtually broke
unemployment is around 50 percent and
now tens of thousands are homeless
with the country's main port destroyed
there are more questions
about the food supply habibata is a
writer with beirut report
he compares the country to a pool with
no lifeguard
there's no government really it's and
and and then you throw a massive
mushroom cloud
bomb into the whole thing i mean it's
just unreal
ceblany and her husband returned to the
site of their unforgettable wedding
shoot
i was shocked i was i was wondering what
happened
am i going to die how i'm going to die
so many lives were lost and many more
have been shattered crystal gomez in
global news
london it was 2700 tons of ammonium
nitrate that blew up
in beirut so what is it and how
dangerous is it
ammonium nitrate is a chemical component
that's most commonly used in fertilizers
it's also used to create explosives for
mining and has been used in terrorist
attacks
it's produced as small pellets or prills
is made all over the world and is
relatively cheap to buy
on its own it's safe to handle but in a
fire
it acts as a powerful accelerant many
countries have regulations about the
handling and storage of large amounts of
ammonium nitrate
including canada if it's stored
improperly for too long it decays
absorbs moisture and forms into a
rock-like mast
if fire reaches it then the chemical
reaction is much more intense
it's happened before in 2015 ammonium
nitrate and other chemicals exploded at
a port in china
killing more than 170 people and in 1947
a blast on board a cargo ship in texas
city
claimed between 400 and 600 lives the
deadliest industrial accident in u.s
history
and in 1995 timothy mcveigh used two
tons of ammonium nitrate
to create a bomb in oklahoma city which
obliterated a federal building
and killed 168 people
nearly 11 000 canadians are registered
as being in lebanon and many of their
friends and family are here scrambling
to connect
and to find ways to help mike trolley
reports
there was a moment of uncertainty as the
lights went out at this
church and then all hell broke loose
people scrambled for cover grabbing
screaming children
i don't want to die they yelled and as
videos like these were uploaded
lebanese canadians scrambled to call
their families overseas
rima mamari has over 30 relatives in
beirut alone
they all survived but not without some
tense moments
her cousin's husband had to climb past
bodies to get to his parents apartment
he has to pull them out from underneath
rubble and glass and because
his mom in particular was injured so
badly
he had to carry her down 10 flights of
stairs
put him put her in his own car and and
get her to a hospital that would take
her
momari like so many others says she felt
helpless living an ocean away
and for lebanese canadians over the age
of 30
pictures of the aftermath brought back
some bad memories
when i looked at the video and i saw how
the explosion happened
it reminded me and it gave me a big
flashback to a lot of things that
i thought i'm over it i thought i'm not
going to be there
any
anymore but clearly it's not
mohammed fakhe remembers when beirut was
a war zone during the civil war
in the 1980s and then in the 2000s more
conflict
this time with israel the lebanese sadly
are used to picking up the pieces but
this time
might be more difficult even before the
pandemic it was a country
crippled with debt poverty and political
corruption so extreme
lebanese canadians aren't sure where to
send relief money
people in lebanon have been already
thinking how are we gonna do this day by
day they haven't really thought
of like the next five ten years
especially with the pandemic going on so
at this point
like it's just a matter of survival
mike drolite global news toronto
countries around the world are sending
support to beirut france which has
strong ties to lebanon flew in a search
and rescue team to help
crews on the ground teams from turkey
the netherlands germany and russia are
also being mobilized
several other countries including qatar
and greece have shipped in
medical supplies the uk norway and
australia
pledged millions of dollars in support
and canada's international development
minister has just announced the federal
government will contribute at least five
million dollars
in support to lebanon it will go to
humanitarian agencies
like the red cross the disaster in
beirut
has delayed a long-awaited ruling from a
u.n backed tribunal into the
assassination of lebanon's former prime
minister rafika riri
hariri was killed in a car bombing in
2005 just a few kilometers from the
scene of tuesday's blast
21 others were killed in that attack the
verdict was due on friday
it's now been postponed until august
18th the assassination stoked political
and sectarian tensions inside lebanon
and across the middle east
four men all of whom have ties to the
militant group hezbollah were
tried in absentia for planning and
arranging the assassination
none of them are in custody hariri a
billionaire businessman who served five
terms as prime minister was credited
with
with leading the reconstruction of
lebanon after it emerged
from 15 years of civil war
now to the pandemic a vaccine is what
could put an
end to it if it gets produced and if
enough people take it
sourcing enough doses will be critical
demand is expected to be high
and as michael couture reports today the
federal government announced two new
agreements it says will secure
millions of doses for canadians
the government of canada has entered
into agreements with pfizer
and moderna to secure millions of doses
of their vaccine candidates
the announcement has a lot of promise
but lacks details
the minister of procurement wouldn't say
how much it will cost or exactly when
canadians can expect to be vaccinated
explaining a lot depends on approval
from health canada
once that has occurred we are expecting
deliveries if all goes well
in 2021. pfizer says it's hoping to have
up to 1.3 billion doses of its vaccine
ready by 2021.
it sounds like a lot but the united
states has already inked a deal with the
company
for 500 million of those doses obviously
there's going to be a huge demand but
i'm reassured that canada is at least
negotiating to get some vaccines
and that could at least if we get even
some coverage for the most vulnerable
that is likely who will get the first
doses according to the government
it's widely believed the best way to
ensure a stable supply
is to make it here
ottawa based vbi vaccines has been given
56 million dollars of government funding
to accelerate development of its vaccine
because it would be made in canada
the president's ceo says canadians would
be given preferential access to the
vaccine
at a lower price we can produce tens of
millions of doses
at a lower cost so our cost of goods
will be
low you know single digit dollars
however their vaccine is still in the
early stages and might only be ready by
the year 2022
it's why the government also announced a
new vaccine task force
we're working at lightning speed to both
identify
right the right candidates and to make
recommendations on manufacturing
despite all that work all agree with
canada's chief public health officer
who said a vaccine won't be the silver
bullet
to end the pandemic mike liquiter global
news
ottawa the death toll from kovit 19 is
surging around the world
more than 700 thousand people are now
known to have died from it
the united states remains the hardest
hit more than 160
000 people have died there in brazil the
second worst affected country more than
96 000 people have died
and india just recorded the world's
highest death toll in a single day
more than 900 deaths were recorded in 24
hours
australia a country that thought it had
the virus beat
in june just suffered its deadliest day
of the pandemic
the state of victoria recorded 725
new cases and 15 people died most of the
cases are in the state capitol melbourne
where a lockdown has been reimposed
the city has become a study in how a
second wave can hit
masks are now mandatory and a curfew is
in effect from midnight
tough new restrictions go into force
that includes closing all non-essential
businesses
for up to six weeks lots of american
voters are expected to mail it in
this fall coming up concerns the
november election could overwhelm the
u.s postal
service
[Applause]
in exactly 90 days the u.s presidential
election will take place and many voters
are worried about how they'll safely
cast ballots in the middle of a pandemic
interest in voting by mail is surging
even though the president has said it
could be rife with fraud
his critics accuse him of voter
suppression as jackson proskow reports
there may be
another big problem with mail-in votes
the next u.s election will look a lot
different than the last one with an
estimated 50 to 80 million americans
casting their votes at a mailbox
instead of a ballot box feeling it's
safer during the pandemic
it is extremely important to me that our
citizens do not have to decide between
their health
and their right to vote the mail-in
ballots is going to be
they're going to be rigged with his own
poll numbers in free fall
president donald trump who votes by mail
himself
has work to sow doubt florida's got a
great republican governor
suggesting it's only okay to vote by
mail in states that are friendly to him
we have total confidence that if you
mail in your ballot in florida it's
going to matter
mail-in ballots have been around since
the american civil war
and nearly one in four voted by mail in
the 2016 election that trump won
is mainland voting safe and secure
oh indeed it is experts say widespread
voter fraud would be nearly impossible
on top of signature checks and
specialized paper
ballot designs and the machines that
read them can vary greatly
even within the same county there are
more than three thousand counties in the
united states
it's easier to go convince people to
vote for your candidate
than it is to try to manufacture
a a fake election the bigger threat is
the postal system itself
currently under assault by a trump
appointed postmaster general
who has brought in policies that have
slowed mail delivery to a crawl
we're being demanded in one way or
another with these new policies
to delay mail that's against everything
we stand for
time is running out to get it right a
series of errors caused
thousands of ballots to be tossed out in
a recent new york primary
it took six weeks to get results experts
have estimated state voting systems need
billions of dollars now
to pull off the election smoothly the
shift to voting by mail could also give
president trump a window of opportunity
to question the election results
that's because the winner of the
presidency may not be known on election
night
it could take days or weeks to count
mail-in ballots
donna interesting election jackson
prosco in washington thanks
still ahead calgary zoo is running out
of bamboo
and options for two pandas
isaias is starting to lose steam now and
has been downgraded to a post-tropical
storm as it tracks through quebec and
heads for new brunswick
crews are cleaning up in quebec about 38
000 people are still without electricity
in the u.s millions of homes and
businesses also remain without
power the storm clobbered the east coast
of the u.s with winds of up to 112
kilometers an hour
in pennsylvania a roof was torn off at
daycare
and outside cars ended up stacked on top
of each other
tornadoes were confirmed in north
carolina virginia
maryland delaware and new jersey at
least eight people are known to have
died in the storm
at the calgary zoo two pandas that were
supposed to go home to china
are stranded and they're running out of
food the pandas are on loan from china
and the zoo plan to send them back early
because it can't get a secure supply of
bamboo
supplies have to be flown in and that's
been disrupted by the pandemic
now the zoo also hasn't got the approval
for the necessary
international travel permits for the
pandas the zoo's only reliable source of
fresh bamboo right now comes from bc and
that's due to run out in september
fresh bamboo makes up 99 percent of
their diet in an
adult giant panda can eat up to 40
kilograms per day
the pair arrived in canada in 2014 and
were supposed to stay until 2023.
there is an update tonight on a minor
from tanzania the man who became an
instant millionaire in june after he
found the world's largest tanzanite
stones well
now he's hit it big again he earned
another three million dollars we're
discovering another tanzanite stone this
one weighs
over six kilograms add that to more than
the three million dollars paid for his
first find and he's doing all right
the 52 year old originally said he
wanted to build a school and a health
center for his community
and he now says the extra millions will
help push ahead with that plan
bordering bubble next the dual plea for
a travel exemption
between remote communities
a lot of border communities depend on
each other for everyday needs and that's
become
even more apparent in a place that
connects bc and alaska
for more than a century people have
crossed freely but the pandemic has
imposed
new restrictions and the political
leaders of two isolated towns are taking
matters into their own hands
as robin gill explains
it's a tale of two countries with one
community at one border crossing
hider alaska on one side stuart bc on
the other
we are a town of 400 people hyder has
less than 100
and we need each other right now hider
needs stewart for basic amenities
there are two grocery stores and
that's very important there's a hardware
store which
living out in the middle of nowhere is
you know it's an oasis to a lot of
people the interdependence of this area
goes
back to the early 1900s when the
communities were founded as mining towns
even former president barack obama
alluded to this unique relationship
when the prime minister visited
washington in 2016.
up in heider alaska folks head across
the board to celebrate
canada day and folks in stuart british
columbia come over for the fourth of
july
now the border is technically closed
between hyder and stewart
but the alaskan residents can cross into
bc for groceries fuel and to see a
doctor
but only once a week for a few hours so
the municipality and township are
petitioning their respective governments
to make them a bubble that was brought
to the attention of bc's top doctor
it sounds like a reasonable plan my only
concern of course is that we've
started to see a dramatic increases in
cases in the last month in alaska
but there are no cases in these remote
communities
what's going on right now is almost
worse than the virus
how it's splitting communities how it's
splitting
families just like putting a big brick
wall in the middle of our community
they consider each other family and they
may be small town politicians
but they're taking their concerns to the
upper echelons of office
i would like to think that uh washington
and ottawa
would start to think of us as humans and
not as americans and canadians
because in this time of covet 19 family
is what matters robin gill global news
vancouver
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's here in canada is reindeer
lake on the manitoba saskatchewan border
this is the saskatchewan side
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you